sorry this is the last talk of the day
so you politte tired I'll try to keep it
under now if I can so while everyone's
coming in I thought I'd have the slides
on the screen and this talk is about the
main modeling and how the kind of type
system in a function language like
f-sharp or Haskell can do a kind of
domain modeling that's different and so
I thought I'd put up a little quiz at
the beginning how many things are wrong
with this design so this is how you do
it another record type in F sharp you
can see it sort of looks a little bit
like Jason and I'm going to ask you how
many things along with this and we will
through this talk we'll go through and
fix them so before we get started on
that let's just talk about process so if
you think of the software development
process like a pipeline if there's an
input and do something in this output
and we normally focus on the software
development side of things we talk about
compilers and tooling and testing and
globally value blah because that's what
we care about
but just like any kind of process if you
have garbage in and get garbage out so
no matter how good your your coding is
if you have bad requirements or unclear
requirements you're going to have a bad
product so this talk is really going to
focus on the requirements side what does
the inputs to our development process
the design phase trying to understand
the requirements trying to document
requirements if we can have good
requirements then there's a whole belief
that we'll have a decent product so this
is the design and that's really the
focus of this talk ok so let's go back
to the challenge I gave you before the
first thing from this thing is it's not
very clear which things are optional
in you no strings could be null or
something is the first name optional is
the middle initial optional is the last
name optional some of them are required
some of them optional it's not at all
clear from this design right so that's a
problem in terms of documentation you
might have tests in the code you might
have a piece of code that says here well
this has to be a non null or non empty
before it's loud but that's in the code
I'm talking about in the design in this
design here that we're looking at so in
this case the middle initial is optional
and the other fields are required it's
not at all clear so that's we're going
to try and change our design to fix that
what about the constraints can the
strings be infinitely long or can they
be you know 32 bits long or 64 bits long
however long strings you know a couple
of gig can they contain non-printable
characters can they attain line feeds
you know there's probably some
constraints on the string right
especially if you have to actually print
it out on a mailing label or on a
envelope or something or you put it in a
database you know for example here we
have a constraint that the string can't
be more than 50 characters and again you
might have some validation rule
somewhere but that's not in the design I
have to go and try and find out which
piece of code has its foundation or than
fine fix it what about which feels a
linked so if we have many people using
the system and somebody updates the
first name when somebody up dates the
last name in two different devices is
that an error what happens if one person
updates the name the other person
updates the email at the same time is
that an error well in this case the name
fields are linked and the email fields
are links they have to be updated at the
same time atomically but you couldn't if
they could be separately bit of one
person up it that you mail no there's
not being a name and that's fine and
that's not clear from this design either
and finding what's the domain logic we
have this some flag here is email
verified and this is set when you know
you put in the email dressing we
actually send you back a link and have
to click the link to prove that your own
that email when is that flag set right
under what circumstances is it set
it's just a boolean it conveys
absolutely
things right now you know you have to
read the documentation to find out so
that's a really bad design let's see if
we can improve this design as well so in
this particular case the logic says if
you change the email you have to reset
at the false because I need to send you
another verification message all right
so which value is optional what are the
constraints which feels a linked and
what's the domain logic f-sharp is great
for all this stuff and I think by the
end of the talk you'll see what I mean
so the main modeling made function lets
me get to this talk my name is Claude
Russian I have a web site F sharp on
coffee comm so obviously a little bias
towards F sharp but these techniques
will actually work with any type system
like this so a camel or Haskell
maybe even Scala so a lot of the ideas
in this talk come from the domain driven
design book if you haven't read it I
highly recommend it but the main point
of this book is you focus on the domain
rather than technology okay I don't care
about the database I don't care about
the web browser I care about what is the
business domain what would people
actually care about when they do their
jobs that's normally considered sort of
a low thing but I like to do it in a
functional way so this is a kind of
intersection of the functional
programming people and the domain
modeling people and we're sort of right
in the middle here so I'm going to first
of all I'm going to demystify functional
programming because a lot of people are
scared by functional programming so I
always stick this at the bean for my
talks I think I won't have to in a few
years but for now I will so if you're
not scared affront to the program that's
great
and then talk about functional
programming for real-world applications
because a lot of people think it's sort
of an academic thing and then I'm going
to talk about what is the F sharp type
system and why is it different from an
object-oriented model of classes and
then we'll actually dive into the meat
of it and actually design this domain
using the types so functional
programming sounds very scary because
there's always words functor and
catabolism and carry
ma nodes and the dreaded monad and you
look at all these words and it's like oh
my god they're awful you know it's too
way too scary
his homer being very scared now I think
it's actually not they're scary but it's
unfamiliar these are words that you
don't know what they mean that doesn't
mean you couldn't know what they mean
and one of the problems is that the
words tend to be kind of mathematical if
you rename the words to something like
it's a functor as a matter ball so the
cat amorphousness a collapsible or
something aggregated or attainable these
words would sound less scary you still
wouldn't know they me I mean here's
Homer he's still kind of puzzled but
it's not it's now just something you
just need to learn it's not something so
scary that I'm going to give up
completely so just be aware that the
concepts are actually not that hard it's
just the words can be off-putting I tell
you what's really scary is on your own
you're programming object-oriented
program has all these really scary words
like polymorphism and inheritance and
interface generics and covariance and
solid and solids has five other things
inside it and IO C and di and ABC LM
procedure what makes you think that
functional programming is bad like
object or program is way scarier than
front something there's all these things
you have to know all these strange
terminology you have to understand right
this is not scary to you because you
probably know other stuff so I guess
it's my point is if you know if it seems
quite sensible and if you don't know it
it seems scary so please don't be put
off by the terminology so the thing in
this talk is we actually don't need
either stuff in this talk we're not
going to be doing any of this stuff
no monads in this talk so monad for you
talk we're going to be talking about
everything else other than blow notes
all right so that's my little rant on
please don't be scared let's talk about
real-world applications so a lot of
people heard that functional programming
is good for mathematical stuff and it's
good of algorithms and it's good for
parallel processing but you need a PhD
to understand it
right well it's true that it is good for
mathematical stuff and it's good for
algorithms and so on but it's not true
that you the PhD you can you know like I
say it's actually really simple once you
get the hang of it so what I think
functional programming is really good
for is boring line of business
applications okay which I call blubbers
so this is what most of us do in our day
job probably it's enterprise software
it's accountants its inventory
management fulfillment ecommerce
websites I don't know but it's pretty
boring I mean we know mostly it's not
exactly the most exciting stuff but if
you think about blob a development
there's some things that you really need
you need to express requirements clearly
because you're trying to communicate
with people who are clueless you need a
rapid development cycle because you want
to get the stuff out there before the
first emerge changing their mind you
want high quality deliverables because
you don't want to have to go back and
fix a bug from six months ago when you
have swamped with stuff today right so
these are very important things and
what's interesting is that these are the
same principles of the agile movement
has and they also came from global
development they came from a payroll
system I think originally so F sharp is
really good for this it's very concise
it's really easy to do Express
requirements clearly and we'll talk
about that today it's a rapid
development cycle because not only can
you do all the unit tests and stuff but
you have an interactive environment you
can do stuff and it's high-quality to
the bubbles and we'll talk about how we
can bake quality into the design so we
can avoid even writing unit tests and of
course the most important things fund
because if you're going to be writing
boring business applications and if you
have fun doing it okay and it happens a
fun is a key word in a shop so there you
go all right so here is a cat and a dog
and this is like functional programming
and beloved elements very happy together
all right so domain driven design so for
people who don't aren't familiar with
domain driven design I'll just quickly
go some of the kind of
points but the the most important about
domain design is about communication is
about you have a model of what you think
what you think is happening and the
domain experts have a model and often
the model of difference and so the point
of domains of design is to get your
model and the domain expert to share the
same model are you basically are working
on the same shared mental model because
remember it's your model that goes into
production right and if your model is
wrong the system will not do what it's
supposed to do and the domain experts
will get angry at you so if you can try
and communicate if you can try and get a
shared model going that's great the only
way to get a shared model is to have
really good communication so let's look
at communication so what is this word un
IO n is red e okay so some people might
think it's unionize right power to the
people and other people especially if
you're chemist you might think it's an
ionized okay so which one is it
which one is it well the answers it's
both of course it depends on the context
so this is the first point about domain
design is there's a context for
everything in business unionized means
one thing and in the chemistry context
it means an ionized so we have to be
very careful about thinking that the
other person understands what we're
saying because there might be different
words here's another one spam okay in a
supermarket spam means canned meat in an
email system spamming junk mail right so
in the different contexts the same word
means something different but okay
that's really obvious what about
products okay this is where it starts
getting painful because in one business
the sales team might think of a product
as something you can sell in the
warehouse management team they think of
product something that's physically in
the warehouse and stuff that you can
sell might not be the same things in the
warehouse there might be slightly
different so there's a potential for
confusion here without customer there's
another one sometimes you see businesses
where they try and create a domain model
that stretches over the entire
enterprise and everyone is supposed to
use the same words that's doomed to
failure because different parts of the
business users
same words mean different things so in
marketing you know a customer means
somebody who can send an email to
somebody who can spam in finance world
the finance department is somebody who
owes you money that's what a customer is
so again different definitions other
customers and the best way one of them
trying to have a generic customer that
matches everybody's thing you divide the
business world or the domain into little
chunks which is called a context a
bounded context and you work inside
those chunks now within those chunks the
word means the same to everybody but
when you cross the boundaries of these
chunks when you get outside your world
and then for something else as well it's
quite possible the word means something
different so another important concept
in domain driven design is the concept
of a ubiquitous language so ubiquitous
language is the language you use in the
shared mental model so a nice a customer
and user customer we're talking about
the same thing and we have a we need a
language to communicate let's all use
the same language okay so in chemistry
here is the victimís language don't you
want to have a polymer now it's very
important that we don't talk techie we
don't say a linked list of molecules or
something we use the words that the
domain experts use which is like a knot
in a polymer we don't say a linked list
even though we may implement that in our
code it's very important that the code
uses these terms the same terminology so
that when I look at the code
I see the domain model and we call this
the ubiquitous language and of course
every domain has their own ubiquitous
language so in sales you might have a
product on a customer and the tracking
and again in a different domain same in
another side a little bit because
language some of the words are the same
but they mean something different
because it's a different context so
here's some code let's look at actually
how you do this can you guess what this
code is what kind of domain are we
talking about here any ideas well first
of all you can see I've got clear there
it's a card game now you might think
well it's obviously a card game but for
example if I didn't say it was a card
game then the word suits could be
to do with clothing right and maybe the
word hand was something to do with you
know medicine doctors as an I don't know
but um the fact that there's a card game
context then these words make sense
within the card game context so that's
the bounded context and then this is the
ubiquitous language genocide all these
are the nouns and the verbs that you use
in that context so this is f sharp code
let me explain it to you quickly so the
vertical bar means a choice so a suit is
a club or a diamond or a spade or heart
rank is a two or three or up to an ace
the card is a pair so that little thing
means a pair and we'll see why we use
multiplication
giman community R so the card is a pair
of a suit and a rank a hand is a list of
cards a deck is a list of cards a player
is a name plus a hand and a game as a
deck that's a list of players the list I
just built into a chart is very nice and
here's a verb so when you see this arrow
in F sharp that means it's a function so
this is a function where the input the
thing on the left hand side is a deck
and the output the thing on the right
hand side is a deck and a card a pair so
I can read this and say well the input
is a deck the output when ideal is a new
deck because the deck is going to be
immutable and there's also going to be a
card on the table so that's what the
output is and when I pick up a card from
the table the input is my hand and the
card on the table that's the input the
pair and the output is my new hand and
the card on tables disappeared so this
is a documentation of that the nouns
involved and the verbs involved so
here's a question do you think this is a
reasonable amount of code to write to
document this domain basically a page
code I would say yeah not bad I've got
like you know nine different things on
on one slide pretty good do you think a
non programmer could understand this if
I if I was showing it something I say
you know I'm not sure you know is there
is a diamond one of the suits or
something they could correct me and say
yes it is I know it isn't whatever you
know if I've missed something they could
probably check it
one of the things about this model is
it's what we call persistence
persistence ignorant
there's nothing about databases there's
nothing about foreign keys
there's nothing about primary keys
there's nothing about tables
there's nothing about classes there's
nothing about inheritance there's
nothing about interfaces
there's nothing except the domain this
is purely all about the domain this is
why it's called the main driven design
is not called object-oriented design
it's not called database driven design
domain dove in design the whole point is
to focus on what's important in the
domain and everything else is irrelevant
right now so what's interesting is the
design this is the design and it's also
compatible code one of the goals of
agile development you know is to make
the code be the design because if you
have the design and the separate UML
diagram or a separate document it's
always going to get out of sync so you
can keep the design and code in sync
that's fantastic and the best way to
keep the design and the code in sync is
to be its have the design in the code so
I think this is a great example of how
you can do this so this is not
pseudocode this is executable code you
could stick this is like the first file
in your f sharp project and it kind of
defined the domain for the rest of the
project so we don't need any stinking
UML diagrams in our F sharp driven
design here
all right so that's the basics of domain
driven design I kind of like the key
ideas so let's look at the F sharp type
system and C wise I think it's really
good for doing this the exit up type
system is what they call an algebraic
type system algebra just like X's and
Y's and adding and multiplying things
we'll see it's a kind of mathematical
word so I actually prefer composable so
composable means you can glue things
together like Lego and you can build
bigger things from smaller things so
there you go this and Lego right so in
the F sharp license well first of all F
sharp types are not
they're just data structures so they
don't have any behavior which means it's
really easy to glue them together
because you don't have to worry about
what is the behavior of them when
they're going to get that as a different
problem so to create a new type you can
just glue them together in two different
ways you can multiply them together and
you can add them together okay now that
sounds a bit weird but how can you not
apply a type how can you add a type what
does it mean so let's look at what this
means okay so here's a function and
we're going to use the classic thing as
a functions with a box and there's an
input and as an output so for example
the add one function the input is a list
of numbers so the input is one of the
integers from the list of integers and
the output is another one of the
integers from the disturbances okay and
in F sharp we write this as an int arrow
int meaning enters the input and enters
the output with the error telling you
there's a function so that's how you you
know there's a set of integers which
could be the possible inputs what
happens if the input is a pair let's say
we want to add a pair of numbers
together and and you know the output we
can say well that's an integer but what
is the input how can we define what the
input type is when in object-oriented
would would define a pair class we're
not going to do that we're going to
build a class we're going to build a
type by composing listing types right so
let's have a look at this if you think
about it the pair means you have a pile
you take one from the first pile and one
from the second pile right so if there
are four things in the first pile and
there are four things in the second pile
how many possible pairs are there
altogether 16 yes four times four
there's 16 possible combinations all
right so this is this is where the
multiplication comes in okay what about
if you have a pair of boolean's okay so
there's two possible billions in the
first pile to possible Williams in the
second pile how many possible pairs are
there there's four possible pairs it's
two times two
so we call this a we call them like
multiplying the types so a pair of intz
is written is in two times int and a
pair of billions is written as all times
ball okay so that's why we use the
multiplication and we call these kinds
of things product types prototypes so
here's an example use okay works very
theoretical let's look at a real example
let's say we want to model people's
birthdays okay so what is a birthday
well a birthday is a person and a date I
mean get a pick a person a typical date
that makes somebody's birthday so we're
going to say well there's all the
possible people and all possible dates
and the combination you multiply them
together gives you all the possible
birthdays all right so we're just going
to say a birthday is a person times a
date so that's our type we've created a
new type that we can actually use in our
code the representatives all right so
that's the multiplication and I also
said you can add types together what
does that mean so let's say we have a
function that tells you whether you have
a fever or not so we're going to pass in
your temperature and it's going to
return a boolean true or false but the
problem is is the temperature in
Fahrenheit or is it in Celsius well we
want to design our function so that
works with both of them so the input is
a Fahrenheit or Celsius how can we model
them well let's say that there are four
possible Fahrenheit temperatures
obviously they're more than that and
let's say there are four possible
Celsius temperatures how many possible
inputs are there eight thank you
there's eight there's four possible from
this but it's 4 from this part or 4 from
this part so that's eight possible
combinations and that's why we call it
an addition right because it's this pile
plus this part now in this case they
might both be integers or something so
we need to distinguish between the
Fahrenheit cases and the Celsius cases
so when we write our code we're going to
have to tag
saying well this is the found high case
this is the Celsius case and we write
you like this we say the temperature
type is a choice between an F where
there's an insulated with it or a sea
where there's a float associated with it
so that's how rude right
a choice type or some type okay it's a
choice between these two things and this
is the kind of type that you don't have
in c-sharp this is very unique to sort
of functional programming so choice
types are really really useful for
domain modeling I mean here is a payment
method and it says okay this is a cash
there's a choice there's three choices
you can take cash you can take a check
or you can take a credit card if you
take cash there's no other information
associated with it if you take a check
there's a check number if you take a
credit card there's a pair and the pair
is a card type and a card number so in
this one type we've actually got quite a
lot of domain knowledge very compactly
written make sense so there we go check
number and so what's nice is each choice
can have its own set of data associated
with it
now once we've got one of these choice
types how do we actually work with it
and this is where the concept called
pattern matching comes in so let's say
we have a payment methods if we want to
print it the way it works is we
basically deconstruct it in the same way
that it was constructed so we have to
have a case there's three possible cases
in the data type so we have to have
three possible choices when we analyze
it so we do this match it's like we're
going to do a pattern match and there
are three possible cases the first cases
is cash the second case is a check and
the third case is as a card and what's
interesting is when it does the
deconstruction it also extracts the
Associated data so you don't have to
like find out like you know deficit is
it this kind of class and then if it's
this kind of class cast it to a class
and then the extracting it does it all
in one step very nice so if you think
about the object-oriented version of
this so I wanted to implement this kind
of payment method in our what I'd pull
in to do is create you know a base class
or interface or something and then I
have to create three separate sub
classes that implement that payment
method that's fine but it's kind of
annoying because this interface there's
nothing in there there's no common
behavior it's just data so this would be
a like a method list interface or marker
interface which is always kind of a bit
of an anti-pattern and and the other
problem is the you doing c-sharp you
probably have a different file for each
of these things so your code is sort of
scattered all around and your your data
modeling code is going to mixed in with
your implementation code which is kind
of annoying if you wanted to find out
all the methods you'd have to look at
all the different files and most
importantly I think is that this is it
with inheritance it's an open set of
choices write anything that implements I
penguin ethic is valid so for example if
I create a thing called evil and it
implements our payment method that will
be fine now sometimes that is useful to
be able to extend the thing but often in
business modeling you actually want a
restricted set of cases it's like I only
accept these three payment methods
just add another paint method without
like changing quite a lot of stuff in
the business it's not just as simple as
inheriting from something and
implementing you know this has to be
more complicated than that
so if you go to the F sharp model what's
nice is that all the choices in one
place and it's a closed set of options
it's like you know exactly it's only
these three choices and the extra data
that put these choices right there
in your face you don't have to like
search or management class it's right by
pair so from a modeling point of view
this kind of approach is very very nice
so if you think about types in most
programming languages we think of types
is sort of a an annotation that helps
you type check you know you make sure
this is integer it's not a string it's
not a boolean so we think of it's just
something that helps the compiler you
know stay accurate but what we're doing
here is we're doing using types as a
terrain modeling tool so when we say
that we're dealing is a deck and you
know the inputs and the outputs and
stuff this is not about type checking
this is about modeling your domain so
we're using types for two things and
what's cool is that in a language like F
sharp you can get both at once you get
the type checking and you also get the
domain modeling which means that the
type checker the compiler can check your
domain logic for you okay so if you have
a good static type system it's almost
like having compile time unit tests you
literally will not be able to write code
that doesn't match the domain model you
don't have to write a a unit test to
test something because it literally
won't compile it is wrong and we'll see
an example of that shortly
so type all the things it's all very
good all right so there's the type
system now let's take it out for spin
let's see what can we do with it
so the first thing is we talked about we
want to have some sort of optional
values right we want to say something's
optional we don't want it to be you know
we want to make it very clear there's
optional so how can we do that so here's
our is our personal name and that will
the middle one is optional
so how do we represent optional values
well let's kind of go back the beginning
let's say that we have a length function
that takes a string as input and spits
out an int as output right so the input
is a list of possible Springs now one of
the problems in most type systems is
that null is a valid string okay null is
in the list of things that you can pass
into this function and that's a problem
because know is not a string you can't
set phasers to no it just doesn't make
any sense you know so this null is
really bad having null as a valid value
for a string is really bad
because it's not really a string it's
pretending to be a string but when you
actually use it it will blow up in your
face the compiler work captured the
compiler says yeah sure null so string
no problem and then when you try and
access the length of the string of in a
crash so I like to say that null is sort
of the cerumen of static typing he's
going to pretend to be your friend is
going to stab you in the back when
you're not looking so so okay so nulls
are really bad so in functional
languages nulls are not allowed to be
part of the bad set of values okay so we
can't model an optional thing by saying
yeah we just use null to me that's
missing what we really want to do is
model it using what we described you
want to say well it's either you know a
valid string or it's missing okay how
can we model that in our type system
well I think we've seen this it's either
one of these things or it's one of these
other things so we model it as a choice
it's either a string or it's a nothing
all right so it's a it's a plus source
of some type so we're going to tag the
top one with some string and we're going
to tag the bottom one with nothing and
then we can define a type like this is
optional string it's either something
and there's a string associated with it
or it's nothing all right so this is how
we would model an optional string using
our very cool
type system alright this is awesome and
we get very excited by this and say yeah
optional strings fantastic and then
actually we also need an optional
integer oh yeah we need an optional
boolean and I think you can see there's
something wrong with this because
there's quite a lot of duplicate code so
this is where we say okay let's not
rewrite this over and over every
possible type let's make it generic
version okay and here's the generic
version
it's called option it's a built-in type
in a sharp you don't have to define it
and that little tick T is f sharp spy of
saying it's a generic so in c-sharp it
doesn't have a ticket and intercept it
does have a tick so that's a generic
type and then we can say okay so the
middle initial is not just a string it's
an option of a string and one of the
nice things in F sharp is you can
actually put it backwards you can see as
a string option so this looks very nice
I think if I say first one's a string
second one's an optional string and the
third one's a string that's a nice
design and it's captured the intent of
which ones are required and in F sharp
if it's if it's not optional it's
required that's basically a rule of
thumb
all right another kind of thing we can
do is what I call single choice types so
a single choice type is one of these
choice types except there's only one
choice right
so hopefully here's an email and there's
only one choice of email here's another
one customer ID and there's only one
choice customer ID why would you do
something as silly as only having one
choice all right well if you think about
it an email address isn't a string it's
a wrapper for a string right it may be
represented as a stream kind scene but
that email address is not a string
because there's constraints around it it
has to have an out sign and it has to be
less than hundred characters and you
know and so on so it's not just a normal
string a custom ID is not an integer it
might be represented by an integer in
your database but it's not that industry
you can't add five to a customer ID you
can't you know take the square root of a
custom idea just just making sense so
these things are not you have to make a
distinction between what it is whether
the main point of view and what it is
from the representation point of view
and what we want to do is represent
there's a thing called an email address
in the domain
there's a thing called accustom ID and
they are distinct the fact that there's
a representation behind the scenes is
not relevant to the domain model so what
we do something like this an email
address is an email address it wraps a
string but it's not a string a phone
number wraps a string but it's not a
string and as soon as we do this we now
have distinct types so an email address
and a phone number and now different
types and it cannot be mixed up you
can't accidentally pass a phone number
to the email address okay even even
though the strings behind the scenes
they're now completely different types
and of course you can do this in object
you could create a special object that
contains a value it's different and for
example custom ID and an order ID there
are different types right you shouldn't
mix up an order ID in a custom ID that
could be really bad so doing these
single choice types allow us to do that
so let's create the email address so we
pass in a string and we have some
horrible regex that checks whether it's
got an out sign in it or whatever so if
it does match the regex
we're going to wrap that string in the
email address and return it and if it
doesn't match the regex what are we
going to do we're going to throw an
exception we're going to return null oh
you can't do that what we need to do is
say ok you gave me a string that I can't
handle I have to give you nothing back
so what we have to do is make a
distinction between something and
nothing so rather than just giving you
the emails respec I'm going to give you
some email address back and if it
doesn't work I'm going to give you
nothing back so if you look at the type
signature the original one said you give
me a string and I'll give you back an
email address and it's like no you give
me a string and I might give you back an
emitters
I'll optionally give you back images if
you give me a good string and if you
don't give me a good string I'll give
you nothing back so now what we've done
is it's now in the dock that the code is
being document is documenting the fact
that it might not always work I think so
well than just throwing exception I
don't have to read the documentation I
can just look at this and says yeah you
know you might not work there's some
validation going on another very useful
type is a constrain string right we have
you know a string that has to be 50
characters or less and we do the same
things like if the length is 50 is good
and if the length is not 50 it is longer
than 50 or something that's bad so again
if we look at the signature you give me
a string and I might give you back a
string 50 or I might not so you have to
handle that but in F sharp these things
are immutable so once you have got a
string 50 or once you've got an email
address you never have to check it ever
again nobody can change it after it's
been created so you never have to do any
kind of defensive programming the
initial thing of like when you've loaded
from the database so you've parsing the
JSON for whatever's you have to do this
checking but after that you never have
to check whether it's null you know how
to check whether it's valid you never
have to check it is it going to fit in
the database because the strings too
long so the defensive programming sort
of goes away once you've done the
initial has been a foundation of the
edges of your app there's a lot less
code you have to write inside the app
here's another good one this is a
website they need and you can order nine
hundred nine nine thousand nine or nine
nine things that's a problem that's
probably a bug why is it bug because the
person writing website probably isn't
int as their quantity right so that's
not that's not right how can we stop
people using an int well we say okay
we're not going to use me we're going to
use a special type called an order line
quantity it's different from in it it's
the main specific type it's just for
this particular domain an order line as
a special thing it's not a normal in
again you can't multiply it by five and
stuff so we're creating a new type just
to represent one thing in the domain
okay and how many people ever do this
how often do you write a new class just
to represent a little thing like an
integer a lot of times we can't be
bothered because it's too much work and
then one of these days we have a bug
because we have a negative number in our
order qty or something this one you can
never have a bug because let's say we we
can do the validation when we plate it
and if it is valid it's a new one and if
it's not valid it's a bad one so again
once we've got this or line quantity
it's immutable it can never change and
it can never be bad we never have to
check it ever again
all right so let's revisit the challenge
we had our original contacts so the
first thing we did is we recreated the
way of making optional stuff really
visible it was this different type the
second thing is we now have special
types for each of these wheels to make
it very clear it's not just a normal
string it's a 50 character string it's
not just a string is an email address
okay by creating special types this is
now more self documenting and it's also
more self validation - the other thing
is we talked about is keeping them
separate well of course it's really easy
we just create two separate types each
one is an atomic thing and then we
create a new contacts which has the name
and the email content info so we've now
made it very clear that these are
separate on of things and we can now
pass this in when we persist these
things we can say well I want to save
the person lame I want to save the email
contact info those will be separate
transactions and the daily basis of a we
don't have to worry about them climbing
all right there's one thing we forgot
about which is this email verified flag
so let's have a look at that in more
detail there's some rules around this
okay if the email has changed we have to
reset it to false okay and we should
have a rule that we can only set the
verified flag by special verification
service because when we verify you know
you click the link in the some kind of
hash code you check the hash code
matches the email and if that's all good
we've got a very email we want to make
sure that rule is followed we don't want
anyone just verifying it because that
could open us up it could be a security
issue if I could if I could hack into
the system and change the email verify
flag then I could send myself a password
reset message you know to the wrong
email address and so on so it's really
bad we really want these rules to be
followed as it stands now the design
does not communicate these rules so can
we embed these rules in the design okay
not in some documentation not in some
piece of code that checks validation
something literally in the design so
that's the next challenge all right so
right now anyone who set this true
there's nothing it's just asking for
trouble
all right so what we're going to do is
create a new type and one of the rules
in domain modeling in a sharp is there's
no problem that can't be solved by
wrapping it in another type okay so we
have our email address type and we're
going to wrap it in another type called
a verified email all right we're going
to take and get another type and now
we're going to have our verification
service and the verification service for
its input it takes a normal email
address and it takes some sort of hash
and it spits out a verified email or
maybe not it's maybe the verification
verification has doesn't match so it's
very clear that this is returning you
know you give me email address I might
give you back a verified email so it's
now very clear you can tell straight
away from this didn't mind our work you
don't have to look and see does it throw
an exception or something and then what
we also do is make this verify the email
type a private constructor so that the
only person who created is the
verification service so that's just like
any any kind of thing you can just make
it a private sort of type and then now
we do now we go back now we've got this
thing we go back to our original thing
and we say rather than saying there's a
flag we say it's a choice so it's either
an unverified email address or it's a
verified verified email address okay so
there's a choice of two things and
what's cool is that in order to use the
unverified choice all we need is a
regular email address and I can create
an email that's that's fine but to
create the verified choice I'm going to
need a verified email where can I get a
verified email form well I can't create
it myself because it's private the only
way I can get a verified email is from
the verification service because it's
the only one has permission to write it
so by doing this I have actually
embedded those business rules right in
the design okay I've guaranteed I don't
have to write a unit test for this
anymore because the code is the design
could capsulate those rules and not only
does that it also you know looks nice
okay we'll see in a minute
so here's our self completed challenge
email address we've got all these new
types before we had one type and now
we've got email address you've got a
verified email as I
male contact okay we've got a personal
name we've got a contact we've got
spring 50 in Ozone so let's go back and
visit the challenge which manager
optional what the constraints which
feels linked and what's the domain logic
so we can clearly see which values are
optional because they've got an option
next to it okay that's right in in my
face I don't have to go and read the
documentation what the constraints will
is really obvious this is a 50 character
string this is a 1 character string and
so on
again I don't have to read the
documentation I don't have to dive into
the code looking the validation rules or
anything which feels a links we've now
broken the original thing into two these
pieces I can show you haven't got every
detail in here but you could also show
that they get updated separately and
it's the domain logic clear yes so
before we had a boolean flag and now we
have a choice and what's interesting is
that the bigoted language the set of
words that we use to talk about the
domain has evolved as we've done this
process because originally we just had
you know a contact and everything was a
string and a boolean and now we have
things like we have a concept called an
email address and we have a concept
called a verified email address and we
have a concept called a personal name
and a concept called an email contact
and so on this is these are the words
that business reduce I mean we've
actually discovered something not only
have we got a better design we've also
got a design actually reflects the
terminology that the business would use
when they're talking about this thing so
this is good so we've actually killed
two birds with one stone
better design and a more accurate
characterization of the model from a
business point of view and of course
this is all compatible code this is not
a Word document and this is not a UML
diagram all right let's do one more
thing making illegal states
unrepresentable so sometime later we
decide to add an address so well as
having an email a contact could have an
address and a postal address as well
okay fair enough now the business says
you know we need a business rule a
contact must have an email address or
postal address
sounds sensible all right so let's look
at this design does this design meet the
requirements right it's like we've got
these two fields email and address right
no it doesn't because remember what I
said everything is required unless you
say it's optional is required so this
design says that the email and the
address are both required fields that's
not what I said I said I could be one or
the other right all right let's make
them both optional well that doesn't
work either because they could both be
missing and that doesn't meet the rule
either we said we need to have one or
the other right but they can't both be
missing so how can we model this okay
there's a great phrase make illegal
states unrepresentable so rather than
saying okay well they can't both be
missing but we'll put a unit test in
we'll put some validation in we'll try
and make sure that never happens it's
like no don't do that try and make sure
the design captures the business rule so
you literally can't happen you literally
cannot light codes that doesn't meet the
business rule okay how can we do that
well if you think about it a contact
must have an email or post address what
does that mean well it means that you
either have an email us or they have a
personal address or they have both okay
that's three possibilities those are the
three possibilities and then missing
other than missing there's not a
possibility so there's three choices how
do we model something with three choices
well we've seen how to do this right we
say well it's an email only or lesson
dress only or it's both so now we have a
type the represents of three choices and
what's great about this is like the
choice where they're both missing is not
an available choice it literally cannot
happen there's not the top fold will not
compile it's just not there not only
that it also documents it communicates
if I come across this code and I say
well you know what are the business
rules around these things it's like well
yeah you can either have one or even how
the other wouldn't have both so it's a
self-documenting code which is very nice
and then we take this choice and we
stick it in our context so the
requirements are now included in the
type system we don't have to write unit
tests that's great the code is also self
documenting which is great
all right so we can build this thing up
now we've got yet another type okay we
start off with one type now we have like
twenty types so the types really not
apply luckily they're all really short
and they all fit in one page so that's
good so before they were separate and
after afterwards we've merged them into
one time all right this is awesome so
static types for domain modeling they're
almost as awesome as a cat on a unicorn
not maybe not as quite as awesome but I
think they're pretty awesome let's do
one mother one more little tweak
chances are the business doesn't really
want that rule that's what they said
they wanted as always what they say the
one is maybe not what they really want
and now go back to them and say is that
what you really want so actually now all
we want is we have to have at least one
way of being contacted okay I don't care
first of all incentives kind of looks
kind of ugly so we just say you have to
have at least one way up in contact it's
fine how do we model that well we say
here's all different ways you can be
contacted you can be contacted by email
who can be contacted by postal address
we could add you know Twitter or Skype
or something those are different ways
have been contacted and then when we
have a contact we have two fields one is
the primary contact info and the second
second one is the secondary contact
enter and it's very clear from this
design that the primary one is a
required fields and the second one is
optional so you have to have at least
one way of being contacted and you might
have a second way of being contacted as
well it's not quite the same because you
could have two email addresses this
officer it's not exactly the same logic
as the previous one so let's look at
what we've covered I talked about this
challenge right could we make that
original design better I talked about
your victus language I talked about
self-documenting designs I talked about
algebraic types and products and sums
and using choices to model things rather
than inheritance this would kind of key
takeaway and then we talked about
designing with types and using options
instead of null using these single case
unions to wrap types and making illegal
states representable kind of trying to
capture the domain rule
in the pipe system directly so that's a
good time to stop there I think there's
a lot of things I can't cover right now
I could talk about states state machines
that's a really interesting one how does
services work and love of law there's
lots of stuff to talk about but I'm not
going to talk about them
thank you for just the end of the day so
okay the slides and the video for this
talk will be on my website if shop for
fun and profit coms slash DVD and in
fact they're already there because I've
done this talk before so if you want to
see this talk again or you want to look
at the slides that's all there if you
want consulting business F sharp works
if you want to know more about F sharp
if you think their shop is just awesome
go to F sharp that all you can download
it it's a cross-platform language it
works on a Mac it works on Linux it
works in Visual Studio but it also works
in vs codes you don't need to have a
whole video studio thing if you don't
want to and you can also join their shop
foundation for free and then participate
in the slack channel and finally I have
a book coming out soon called domain
modeling main functional what a
coincidence the same title as let's talk
so it's just the it's in the early
access it's in the beta right now it's
not finished you can buy it now if you
like if you want if you're desperate to
read it or you can wait a couple of
months and you can get it when it's
finally ready but I hope you will like
it it's basically the store extended
into a book and I think that is it so
thanks very much
and of course feel free to grab me ask
questions whatever and there's a by the
way if you're interested in a shop
there's a functional lab every day at
1:40 it's in room 10 you have to go out
the towards its front and then go up the
stairs so if you if you want to see some
demos of this I can demo this stuff to
you directly if you're interested so
definitely check out the functional lab
Cheers